you'll be able to view the various
courses and example projects so here uh
if you're interested in let's say
machine learning you can simply enter
the keyword that is machine learning
and you'll be able to see the various
courses and example projects that makes
you solve machine learning related
topics so you could go through it at
your own pace under a diverse range of
topics that you could search on and now
coming to the part where I was
explaining about updates new profile so
how do you do that for that you can
click on the tab that says welcome back
with your email ID
and once you click here you will be able
to see a button that says profile so
here is the part that lets you uh update
your account so here uh please make sure
that you upload a profile image and you
edit your educational background with
your uh education background and
research interest and please make sure
that the name will always be in proper
capitalization and link your social
media handles as well so for example I
have linked my LinkedIn account and my
orc ID
so here under the activity tab the
participants will be able to uh view the
various courses that they are completing
the mentor and the community manager
will be tracking your progress from here
and under the courses tab you'll be able
to see the various courses that you are
currently taking
and once you upload a research project
like gazal bhargava that will be
displayed under the projects Tab and
once you enroll for any of the programs
for instance the research fellowship
program that will be displayed under the
programs tab now how do you uh check
other student projects for that you can
simply click on the tab that says
projects
and here you will be able to see a
diverse range of student projects or on
topics ranging from astrobiology
infectious diseases Precision oncology
Precision medicine machine learning and
so on so you can have a take a look at
all of the example projects at your own
case
and that now I'd like to pass on the
stage to vedikarai our former research
fellow and M Tech graduate from Amity
University Noida to share her journey of
uh being a research fellow at buying
biotech and for that uh we do have a
query from Richard I am unable to sign
into the T by info all right we'll be
looking into that I have mailed you a
step
right so if the participants have no
other queries uh let's move on to the
next part and hear from vedika Rai about
Arjun so over to you vedika
uh can you share your screen vedica and
start with your presentation
yeah I'll do that
thank you
foreign
are you able to see it now
not yet baby girl
okay
okay sure
all right so while we're meeting I would
like to know if the participants have
signed up or if they're having any
queries about signing up on the portal
if so please share them in the chat and
once you have signed up you can put a
yes or a done as well in the chat
vedika would you like me to share your
presentation from my screen yeah you can
do that it is
College
uh let me share it for you
all right so here you go
you can start very good
so good evening everyone I am vedika and
I've been a research fellow for Rome
with omic logic from the last September
month of September and I got introduced
to this uh platform as we had to do a
minor project in college and we were
just looking for internships most of the
tutorials were closed because of the
Corona virus so my juniors introduced me
to this tutorial and I thought yeah it
would be a great opportunity to learn
bioinformatics as you know it's the need
of the hour and most of the drug
designing or looking at the genius
are you able to hear me
having trouble hearing yes yes
okay
so this is how I got started that we had
to do this internship and I mean my
minor project so I came here and I so
I'll talk a little bit about me I have a
basic degree in biotechnology I've also
done my Master's in biotechnology and
can we have the next slide please
so my research in Trista I'm very
interested in neurobiology especially
being able to look at the gut microbiota
and its relationship with brain disease
diseases and development of the brain
then I I also got interested in transfer
cancer transcriptomics when I came here
and virology these are my basic three
interests so interestingly before I came
here I just knew enough bioinformatics
for me to write my midterm exams and
assignments and I can navigate ncbi that
was the kind of person I was and
sometimes I also had to work harder on
other assignments and give them to my
class fellows so they would give me
their bioinformatics assignments and
they would help me with the notes this
is how it was I get started I come here
it's all about bioinformatics I was
excited I'm going to learn something
that's going to teach me about skills
that we can currently use in every field
so and this is how I started and then I
ended up working on two projects can we
have the next slide
foreign
with my research Fellowship we did a
couple of
um projects that actually helped me
understand what the basics of
bioinformatics is all about and we did
the bytes and molecule scores where I
also learned about things like
metagenomics and I learned about a
little bit about astrobiology and then
the basic uh tools that we use in
bioinformatics the databases and a
little bit about statistics then we came
to the transcriptomics course where I
basically got introduced to Next
Generation sequencing and how the
biological data that is generated from
various experiments or if it's even
found in silico we are able to map the
gene expressions and we are able to
learn how the gene sequencing is done
and the with with the help of that data
we can do some statistical analysis we
can look at the pathways that are
involved in diseases we can look at the
molecular mechanisms and we are able to
look at the basics of diseases and also
with the Curative intent and look at
some biomarkers so obviously we've
learned all these Concepts we've learned
the statistics you've learned the
formulas now you also need to put it in
the form of a bioinformatics project so
I also did a course where actually I was
taught how to write reports from start
to finish what the structure is supposed
to be like how you're supposed to ask
your questions because I think that the
question is the Crux of your project if
you have a good research question and
it's strong enough you to differentiate
your data between the disease state in
the non-diseased state or you're able to
look at gene expression which is
involves genes that are highly regulated
or down regulated so we are able to look
at the elements that form the molecular
basis of diseases and we can
differentiate them this was the courses
that I did the next slide please
so my first project was about the
transcriptomics analysis of clinical
data and kobit 19. the goal of this
project was as we know that
um last year the pandemic was in full
swing and we had several waves so we
looked at patients that were mildly
moderately and severely infected in
various days which was like the first
day and after a week the patients were
infected with the virus and we wanted to
correlate the severity of the disease
with the viral load that they were
infected with and what we did was that
we ended up collecting some data from uh
patients which we were able to find on
the jio website as a as in database and
then we performed certain tests on it
and statistical exams and then we ended
up doing the PCA so the PCA it's
basically a dimensionality reduction
it's a tool I know it sounds like a big
word right now for people who are like
me and just got are getting introduced
to bioinformatics but at multiple genes
in multiple conditions we are basically
able to look at them in a unified way
that what direction of the disease are
they taking us to and then we also
looked at the expression of genes of
different kinds and we were able to see
that genes are severely differentially
expressed in the mild and Progressive
stage so it's also because of how your
immune system responds to the disease
and if noted on some Pathways also like
the Jack start pathway and the cytokine
cytokine the separate interactions which
are able to tell the cause of your
disease that if you will be infected
mildly or moderately or it will give you
a severe disease also what was very
interesting to look at
was that
um when we looked at the viral load we
found no differences between people who
were mildly infected and moderately
infected and severely infected we did
find differences in their gene
expression like you can see I've drawn
the plots also and we have a bunch of
points that are segregated on the Bloods
towards its right and the left which
shows us that there are differences in
gene expression but it doesn't mean that
if you have a highly infected viral load
and you're just having mild disease you
will not be able to you know spread the
disease to others so it's also important
for mildly or healthy people to stay
indoors and prevent the spread of the
disease can we have the next slide
then I did another project over here
which was a part of my Master's
dissertation and since I was interested
in cancer biology but I think this feel
like since so many people have been
working on it it's become a bit
repetitive so just to make it more
interesting or make it more fun my
instructor Dr raghav he suggested that I
could look at the tumor microenvironment
as uh what the tumor microenvironment
does is it it's basically a niche of
cells of growth factors of signaling
elements that our leukemia cells are
surrounded with and we should be able to
look at that is the tumor micro
environment also a cause of being able
to
generate this disease state or it's able
to turn the space leukemia the the kind
of leukemia that I worked on it
basically it's basically about B cells
so is it able to drive the proliferation
of the B cells in such a direction that
it becomes disease and what how it
exists in certain kinds of tissues like
the peripheral blood and the lymph node
as we know that the lymph node is
responsible for the growth and for the
proliferation of these Mason cells into
the adult of full grown cells which will
then go on and provide immune responses
again we did some PCA we did some
statistical analysis like the TEAS test
so we could differentiate between
different groups of the disease then we
also looked at the differential gene
expression as you can see over here in a
figure that the genes on the right side
that are outside of the cutoff and are
colored they were highly upregulated and
they were causing certain changes in the
cells such as it could be that the
cell's immune function it could be uh
you know down regulated or within the
cell cycle certain checkpoints if they
are released and the cells are oh and
the genes are overactive it would not be
able to cross the checkpoints in the
correct pathway or the growth of the
cells would not stop at the required
points that will lead to an indefinite
growth uh growth and proliferation of
the cells also we learned that the tumor
micro environment is able to very
significantly affect the progression and
occurrence of this disease as they can
be uh as a tumor micro environment can
make the Dell uh can make the cells
highly refractive to the kind of disease
uh that you're in and the drugs that are
used for it and it also increases the
inflammation that the cells are um
increased to and it's also responsible
for DNA damage in the sense
so this is a brief overview and I'll be
showing you the projects on how to write
these reports and how to go about the
courses in detail can we have the next
slide please
um so like I said I have a degree in
biotechnology but sometimes you know
with the with such degree you're also
interested in looking at other fields so
I am currently working as a market
research training in global uh training
and global data PLC then I would say
that my work is more towards the
business side where we look at the
shares and revenues of companies but we
are able to also map it to the concepts
of biotechnology that we use in making
the medical devices that have just
published but uh it would definitely my
dream job would be to again go back to
research and look at how these molecular
mechanisms are causing diseases and what
differentially expressed genes are there
how do we sequence them and little bit
to be able to touch upon the Curative
approaches I think this would be the
most interesting thing so I'm going to
be working towards that and coming to
the uh the work that I done I had
written a poster about it but if I'm
able to gather more data sets which can
establish a stronger link between the
human micro environment and the
occurrence of the disease or in terms of
the occurrence of the covert disease and
then we draw more diagrams we make it
more systematic we perform more
statistical analysis on it then I can
turn it towards a paper publishing
so now heading to
um the portal I'll be showing you my
portal and then you can take a look at
the courses you can take a look at the
kind of projects that we've done and how
do we submitted
so we have shared the link to verica's
profile in the chat so that the
participants can go through her profile
along this way
so let me do later for you
I'm going to share my screen with you so
you can take a look
would you like to start explaining
vedika
uh yeah we can do that can you go to the
courses section
yes we have the courses section right
now
so as you can see in on your mix logic
profile you will have a section where
you're supposed to talk about your
research interests you can give a little
bio about yourself and then you get
started with the basic courses like I
just said I was also a beginner Advanced
and I mean I barely knew anything about
practical bioinformatics except for what
I had to do in class to get my plates
never knew it would look so fascinating
to me and it would just be very
interesting so you can start start off
with your bytes and molecules course and
then you can also get an introduction to
bioinformatics the introductory course
basically tells you what bioinformatics
is all about and how you can use Big
Data like we know that you know when we
work with such uh on even in research
projects or at a small level you are
required to work with thousands of genes
and you cannot just you know quantify
them at once or you cannot just look at
the differences between them at once so
big data it's very important to learn
those techniques and learn how we can
you know do the uh how we can use it in
bioinformatics then in the bytes and
molecules course you will also get an
overview to the kind of fields that
you're able to use bioinformatics in and
you will get to learn how to use ncbi
you will get to learn how to
um visualize genes and how um you know
the process of transcription translation
the biological part of it works
uh you can do that and uh then you'll
also learn a little bit about proteins
and interestingly I learned that it's
also important to look at the
transcriptome in not just a DNA sequence
over here can you please get to the
transcriptomics course please open it so
we can talk alongside thank you
so like we say that the DNA expression
it is a bit static since you know this
uh the the genetic expression of cells
you are born with it but it's the
transcripts that undergo more
modifications and they will ultimately
lead to the production of the protein
products that are responsible for you
know the occurrence of diseases
or the differences in Pathways or the
watch growth signaling factors Etc
so you will begin with learning NGS and
NGS is also very in technique these days
you will learn how to do the RNA
sequencing you will learn how to prepare
your data for Downstream analysis you
will learn statistics and I think the
most interesting course is to begin with
for me when I learned about rna's rna-c
techniques where we were able to look at
Raw reads and we were able to figure
them out how we map them how we
determine what genes they are then
coming to the differential gene
expression and Gene enrichment which is
something that we also do very often in
our projects and then you can also when
you move on you can go to the machine
learning systems and then you will learn
how to do supervised in unsupervised
machine learning and for those of you
into coding you can learn python you can
learn art these are the languages that
basically we use for coding since I
don't have so much of a coding
background so
my instructor he helped me with the
coding part sometimes we need to
segregate the data sometimes we need to
look at plenty of data so I got help
with that
and uh
you know you can also look at other
kinds of courses like they also have
some demo project courses like the liver
cancer one the one on cobit since last
year Kobe was in full swing so you know
everybody wants to learn that and I
think this also ignited our
um interest in virology again otherwise
mostly people are concentrating towards
neuroscience and cancer biology
so that is that you can take a look at
the courses of your interest and you
will also learn what databases what
tools to use and Within These courses
what is interesting is that you also
have some practice exercises so it's
just not reading up stuff on your own in
theory you'll have these practice
exercises that you can work on yourself
and then you can come back to your
doubts I also felt like to begin with
when I was beginning with these courses
I think it got a bit difficult for me to
understand what these signatures are and
how you use these transcriptomic
strategies and how the G how do you look
at Gene maps and when you have to
combine a lot of approaches it does get
a bit tricky to learn with so your
instructors will help you with that
they'll give you one-on-one classes and
um and the practice exercises yeah like
I said they really help
now coming to the core the projects that
I've worked on
here's another resource that you can
look at just for the Coronavirus and
you'll also learn about a little bit of
the epidemiology you will learn about
how we can back trace it to the
organisms like
we all know the story of Wuhan and how
the coronavirus spread from there and
it's also very related to
bats and pangolins this family of the
virus that's infecting people and that
cause the epidemic so like so we'll just
get to the the covid-19 project
I'll take you through it
so while you write your projects you
have a it's a set of steps that we have
to follow and I think it's something
that we do everywhere even when we write
a report or you want to do a research
paper you will get start off with
collecting your data set then working on
it
um through your materials and methods
section and then you should be able to
derive some
uh con some significant results and you
will be able to look at the data that
way so then you write an abstract about
what you do in the project then you give
an introduction to the theoretical part
like you could talk about what the
coronavirus is all about what are the
stages of the disease and how do people
get infected then you will tell them the
methods that you did like I just talked
about the statistical analysis and the
principle uh repeat the PCA and stuff
like that then you can discuss
what did you learn from the project you
can also talk about your results before
that you obviously you'll be doing the
results first and then the discussion
what is what is it that you can draw and
what can you attribute the diseases to
and it's not only limited to diseases if
you're interested in the
agriculture side or if you're interested
in the microbial side you can also do
projects like that then you'll conclude
your project you'll give your references
and then you'll give an acknowledgment
so this is a format this is like a
standard format that you should keep in
mind when you are writing a project
so basically when I did the covet
project
um what we did was that towards an
introduction we were able to look at uh
the Genome of the covet uh the covet
virus a little bit we got an
introduction to it that it has about uh
you can say it shares about 80 to 90
percent of its uh sequence with bat and
Pangolin virus and then uh
the the gene or I would rather call it
the DNA of the virus
um so the uh the genetic material or the
RNA of the virus it ports for various
um segments of the virus like the uh
orfs and then the envelope and the
membrane and the spike and then the
capsid protein code like we all read
about in our virology classes and
sometimes they also have some accessory
proteins that help the virus penetrate
better into the
sales and cause the disease so this is
some basic introduction to covet and
then what the spike protein of the Kobe
does is that it binds to Ace receptors
which are also some receptors uh that
are like highly concentrated in a heart
and lungs and many uh drugs are also
made against these receptors then the
covet virus from your nasal tractor goes
into your lungs and then whatever the
disease severity has to occur it occurs
so like we collected this data uh for
this uh for this project and we
collected about 180 samples from 98
people which was segregated into the
base day of the disease they were
diagnosed and then a week later or five
days later where you can look at the
profession then we did the PCA for it
where we kept the threshold that if the
gene expression
um uh it occurs Beyond a certain level
then only we will consider it
significant uh which was done in the
quantile normalization step where
basically you will transform the genes
into a bunch which can be compared with
each other because you don't want any
kind of background noise or genes that
are not significant in a very mildly
stress that won't change the course of
the disease uh to affect your results
then you do some differential gene
expression about it you will select
thousands of genes you will cut them
down to the genes that it's that causes
a disease and then you can help with the
help of various diagrams and charts and
bar plots you can look at the results so
we found out that like I've written here
that the covert disease it gives you a
very hyperinflammatory State and there
are various Pathways and uh genes that
you know will also affect the ability of
the immune responses that are whole that
the host will do to the viral proteins
in the form of cytokines Etc
so this was a little technical sci-fi
facts of the project
and then I'll also walk you through the
other project which I had done as part
of my
final final years Master's dissertation
I came back here again because like it
was covered and what would you think of
doing so you know the uh like all these
institutions are foreclosed but I'm so
glad I did it it was there it was a very
interesting project to work on and the
good thing about it it's all of it is so
interactive that you know you're able to
visualize it with your eyes you're able
to dive into genes and you're able to
look at the results instead of just
sitting in class and just reading
theoretically about things which I know
can get a bit dry and uninteresting to
work on
so to begin with for a project you will
also get some data sets uh which you
will like I said you can obtain it from
the jio website or any other database
model related to your disease and then
you can you'll get the counts of the
kind of genes and the gene expression
that occurs in a disease uh you can take
the raw data and then you can work on it
you can perform your statistical tests
you can annotate it to the various Gene
IDs you can look at the pathways that
are involved in the disease
so we'll just get to the introduction in
the method section I can just stop
because you'll basically again get an
idea about what the projects are all
about
so again chronic lymphocytic leukemia it
is a disease that affects uh the B cells
where the immature B cells they are they
undergo such high levels of
proliferation that uh the count crosses
a certain value which is obviously
medically kept as a cut off and it can
cause that's why it can cause various
symptoms and the stages of the disease
so what we did was that we again we
collected some data from jio uh this
time like I said that you know not only
the disease you can also look at the
various types of tissues that are
involved in a disease like we did
peripheral blood and lymph node
and uh we also looked at other
conditions of the kind of cells in the
markers that they showed we chose cd19
because it's highly uh I would say like
a statutory when it comes to this
disease so it helps us differentiate
between healthy and the disease cells
then we again did the PCA we did some uh
differential genius uh special and a lot
of these uh steps were done on the T
bioinfo service platform which is uh
here you can look at the pipelines you
put the data in and you get the results
out with the certain conditions that you
expose your data to
then we had to also statistically
determine that if the gene that
differentially expressed do they even
make any sense for them uh to to be this
way or not so we did that we use certain
formulas and tests and then again we did
the differential gene expression and
with the help of Gene ontology we were
able to concentrate uh the genes that
affect the molecular and biological
functions of the disease so you can use
various online tools you can also code
and look at the uh the kind of diseases
and the genes you're looking at so that
is one thing if we get to the results of
the project you can just see that it
looks very interactive when you do it in
the form of charts and plots and it also
gives you a lot of clarity so like you
can see that the various subgroups of
the disease like lymph node or blood or
the disease or the cells that were
healthy enough
and the unhealthy cells that also had
more purpose we determined them uh their
propensity to cause a disease in the
terms of certain percentages and you see
that how they differentiated on the
charts also you can like I just talked
about in our previous project also that
the upregulated and now exaggerated
genes we can see not only how much they
change and how they change and what
these mutations are able to cause
now coming to the discussion and
conclusion of the project
so we did learn
um that uh with various signaling
Pathways basically there was a very
interesting part we call the notch
pathway that is responsible for uh
causing changes in the tumor micro
environment which is able to cause the
occurrence of this disease and the notch
pathway along with some other signaling
Pathways you know that we usually read
in our cell biology classes uh they will
also affect the tumor microenvironment
which can interact with the cells and
determine the fate of the cells if it
grows into a network of healthy cells or
unhealthy cells
also we can note certain like I've given
the names of certain genes like it is
the pi uh Pi k3cd Gene it is involved in
the proliferation of the cell it is
involved in the development of the cell
and then T Cell receptor signaling like
it tells us that you know it's not just
limited to the B cell proliferation but
the other kinds of immune cells also
they all work in a niche which is where
the micro environment comes in then
certain genes that will affect the
metabolism of proteins and lipids which
can lead to the production of certain
signaling factors which may be faulting
or which may be healthy and uh there are
also genes which can mutate it can um
contribute to the drug resistance or the
reoccurrence of the disease which is
also there and then since we know that
most of these mechanisms are molecular
and they involve the DNA sequences and
stuff so you will also look at
a CLL patients they will have higher
rates of translation and the regulation
by the ribosomes of the genes they will
be lowered so that also lead to the
occurrence of the disease as the
signaling when they occur in this uh the
DNA and RNA it will lead to the
occurrence of uh certain kinds of
infaulty cell cell cycle and the mitotic
spindles may be affected and these are
just like a bunch of um you know
phenomenon that can occur with the
occurrence of this disease
what it can also help us do is it can
locate by we can look at biomarkers that
if we see that there are certain genes
or uh that are differentially expressed
and they can affect certain functions of
the um cells like the DNA repairs will
be altered the signaling Pathways they
will be altered it can cause an
inflammation or the it can affect the
organism of the cell like it may cause
some mitochondrial uh dysfunction in the
cells and it can also uh cause some
faulty occurrence of the cellular
processes and signaling Cycles like we
read about the calcium dependent kinases
and the BCR receptors Etc so this was
about it and when you do it in silico it
also gives you
a very thorough look at what uh like I
worked on the disease side of things so
I think it is a very thorough and a very
interactive way to look at things so I'm
very happy and I'm actually very happy
to be coming back here today to talk
about my projects and my journey as a
research fellow and it was very
interesting and I'm so thankful that I
was able to do this side of
bioinformatics things and I'm always
looking forward to learning more about
that stuff
well thank you for this and if there any
other any questions that you would like
to ask about writing a project or
anything in just in general please feel
free to ask yes uh we do have a query
from uzma manzoor and she's asking have
you done all these courses online
yeah
so smart so like the fellowship that we
did we mostly do it online and you can
see that they have a portal of the
courses so what you're supposed to do is
you're supposed to go with the study
material they will give you certain
videos also in the study material like
when I started with the transcriptomics
course I remember I was able to look at
how the Next Generation sequencing is
done how the
um the the I would say the samples are
prepared how do we map them to the genes
and what strategies are used so you
should be able to uh mostly you will be
doing these courses online and then you
can always get in touch with your
instructors if you have any doubts or if
you are stuck somewhere in doing the
assignments so that is how it works and
they've divided into lessons for each
topic so I think it makes it easier to
understand things when you can go at
your pace and you can start off with the
easier things and then work your way up
that is how we do it
thank you so much and I hope your query
got answered and I have one final query
for you that is uh you have gone uh a
really rigorous training right
completing all the courses and example
projects so uh any uh and you have also
completed two research projects so how
has all these training and all these
mental guidance help you in your present
field of work
okay so that is a question that's very
interesting and very I would say way to
answer it once but right now what I'm
doing is I'm working as a trainee like I
said in the market research field so my
work is more Allied towards you can say
the marketing side of things and how
companies work how do they generate
revenues what their quarterly reports
are and all that so I wouldn't say that
it's so much related to biotechnology
but the kind of products that you look
at when they look at medical devices and
when you look at diseases when you look
at therapies that they perform when you
look at some antimicrobials when you
look at some uh you can say some
scaffolds or tissue repairing devices
like which is something I'm currently
working on
um
so I think when you have a thorough
knowledge of bioinformatics when you're
able to do things in silica you're also
able to do them better in a physical way
of course bioinformatics research is
something in itself it's a very big
field and it also helps you do uh
research like on a lot of drugs or you
know you can look at the like I just we
keep talking about these differentially
expressed genes so when you look at
those uh basics of the disease I think
it obviously helps you understand better
what you're up for and as when you look
at the genetics and you know the
molecular mechanisms or like I said the
upregulated down regulated genes it will
always give you a very thorough
understanding of the disease and if
you're planning or if you're somebody
like me and if you're you know planning
on also getting back to research it's a
very good way to go about bioinformatics
and then open your uh way up to other
fields
what I would like to say thank you so
much vedika that was really wonderful
presentation and you also answered the
question really well and thank you so
much once again we are so glad to have
you back and uh
right thank you so much and uh with that
now we'd like to move on to the next
part of today's webinar that is uh I'd
like to pass on the stage to Dr Mohit
mazumdar who will be talking uh more in
depth about the research fellowship
program and what are the various
resources and registration costs and so
on so with that the state is all yours
uh thank you srigori and thank you
vedika for this wonderful wonderful
presentation and it has been really
great working with you and uh having you
all this while uh working on these
several problems and projects I hope
that with whatever experience you're
gaining right now uh and combining with
what you already know you can shape up
uh whatever you want to do next in a
more you know data driven manner where
you are taking the right kind of
decisions for yourself because now you
have gone through the experience and
maybe replicate some of that and not do
the same mistakes again
so about the next things I would like to
maybe have more interaction with people
who are around so people who have joined
today's session if you guys have any
questions please happy to answer those
um so there is a question about a scope
and clinical chemistry
so it's not my area of research or my
area of you know where where I do work
which is not clinical chemistry but
there is a lot of scope in clinical
chemistry which you can obviously
correlate with
the changes that are happening so
there's a lot of work that has been done
in testing and in in using clinical
trials also so in that we have several
uh different stages where we use
clinical informatics as a tool so a
clinical chemistry and clinical
informatics are two separate things but
they align at some point because of the
use of chemistry in all of this so from
drugs to you know how our body behave
chemistry plays a huge role so that's
vaguely what it is but I mean it would
be best to Google this by because you
will find all the answers you will find
articles you will see that there is a
correlation with what we are doing with
clinical chemistry as well
okay there's a question is in the role
of machine learning in biotechnology
it's a very very uh broad question
because biotechnology includes uh
technology that are developed with the
help of biology which involves biology
so there are like so many different
things that people are doing in
biotechnology which involves you know
food production which involves you know
agriculture which involves biomedical
data science biomedical data biomedical
research which involves Healthcare
research so I think it's it's uh it's
it's playing a huge role in every place
in all of these fields as I say because
what machine learning is is machine
learning is simply data analysis so
machine learning is that you are trying
to learn make the machine learn so that
he the machine can make these complex
analysis
um with much easy with much ease and
also learn to do predictions because
what we are doing in machine learning or
biomedical data science is that what we
are trying to predict we are trying to
predict based on a pattern so whenever
there is like data there is pattern and
that is what uh you would observe like
even while you're driving there's a
pattern in which you're driving then
with in compared to another person when
you're driving you're looking at the
person who is like in front of you
driving another car and predicting that
how how the speed would be how much
distance I have to keep all those
predictions keeps on going in inside
your head so similarly
when we have a lot of information and
this information could be
three-dimensional information uh it is
from protein structures this could be uh
information from the genes that uh just
vedika was discussing about gene
expression so all of this is a big data
now and with this there is always a hope
there is always there is always a
pattern to find and now why this pattern
is important obviously that pattern
helps us to find diseases diagnose them
before it it could happen which could be
a great relief for Humanity if we could
predict the diseases before they happen
and take preventions so that is where
bioinformatics is again playing a huge
role and after after also like having
the disease we have all those samples
where we see stage wise differentiation
between how a disease is progressing so
that could be answered through
bioinformatics through machine learning
and all of that so I hope that answers
your question
uh in that sense so there's another
question can a research Fellowship help
for publishing the papers so kavya um
okay so this question is kind of uh more
relevant to the project so research
Fellowship helps with like helps every
student or every participant to First
learn about the technology and then
apply the technology and then apply it
on an independent research project so
there are different stages so you start
with stage one you learn how to what are
these Technologies how to uh you know
start applying them in real data sets
and that's what the coursework is all
about and also like the at the same time
Mentor mental mentors are associated a
team is there to help you out go through
this process this is very like done
easily with all the resources that we
shared which is learn oh mixed logic and
the topic platform which I it actually
simplifies all of this complex analysis
in a very graphical Manner and then you
you get to develop this understanding
that what kind of data you have to look
into what kind of analysis you can use
and then we have r or python that you
can choose and you can work use those
programming languages to do this on a
command line interface so all of those
things are there so you can do with code
or you can do without code so you don't
have to be a proficient encoding when
you are joining this program but you
will slowly develop an understanding how
to use code for bioinformatics not to
develop your own algorithm because that
requires a very intense training which
is not possible in within the scope of
our training our focus is bioinformatics
and research so yes our our hope is that
you go through that process and you come
up with the publication because many of
the students have done that and have
been able to come up with a publication
so we believe that if you follow the
process if you if you learn with us if
you practice and if you
work on a research project which is
interesting it's kind of doable to
publish that all right there's another
question from
uh we will be we will be guided to start
a project and write a research paper so
yeah it's a question so yes and that's
what I was discussing that the project
has different stages the project starts
with an hypothesis which is what you
would want to develop so any research
area you are interested in and we are
like a company where that offers you to
work on any research area that has all
this data available publicly publicly
available data we are not afraid to work
on any project that we are not discussed
here so if you have any new idea any new
disease any new you know it could be
agriculture it could be biotechnology it
could be any other field related to life
sciences and if there is publicly
available data we are a group of data
scientists who can help you understand
the data correlated with the biology and
then understand also the demand and the
need and then you know think about what
are the outcomes that we could uh do
with that project so that's the in that
uh pipeline but it requires you also to
work at the same time practice and learn
and then uh code work with the team so
all that experience also counts at the
end of the internship and the fellowship
because you go through a team learning
experience working with a team as well
as doing a scientific research project
so all all of that is a really key
feature of This research fellowship
program
okay there's a question by hand uh are
you offering any scholarships for the
beginner researchers from the developing
yes we we we are
so uh I would request all of you to also
reach out to us it's very easy to reach
out to us
um for any sort of you know
communication our team is available
online
and you can reach out to our website you
can email us for all of your queries
related to The Joint you know joining
the program and yes uh maybe I can
quickly show so I'll ask that any of the
team members to maybe share the link for
the registration
uh there are no restrictions so one of
the biggest Advantage for the research
fellowship program is that it's a
fellowship program which means we are
mostly providing all of this in a price
that could sustain the program so it's
not something that
they're doing and we are providing a lot
of resources from our part to make it uh
make it a comprehensive program so yeah
it involves all the all the materials
that are available on omics logic to
learn and
um TV info platform so you will be able
to access all of that so this is what
the research fellowship program is all
about uh okay let me share my screen
quickly and show you how to register and
look for uh I mean get scholarships and
apply for scholarships because we do
offer scholarships and as we are heading
towards the end of the year we have some
scholarships uh available because uh the
scholarships are going to
be an invalid for the new year with New
Year we will start with a new new uh
scholarships that we will be offering
for the winter programs but for now
there are few seats available very few
seats available because uh we recently
we are towards the end of the year and
uh there are some scholarships so there
here you can find out about all of this
in this link and also like you'll be
able to find out the payment process and
all of that here so uh and uh if you are
from developing countries and if you are
from low income countries you can
obviously reach out to us and if you
can't join the research fellowship
program and if you think that it is um
still a little expensive for you to
afford considering the condition that
you are in financial condition you are
in so in that case you can start with
the basic subscription which is like a
really really amazing thing for all of
us here who are these learning by
informatics using bioinformatics because
it's it's just a ten dollar subscription
that allows you to access all the
courses and projects which are available
on learnmics logic it does not involve
Mentor guidance because that is
impossible to cover in that cost so the
mentor guidance and project is what
research Fellowship is all about you can
find out check these payment links and
reach out to us for scholarships for
research fellowship program but if you
can't do it you should do this I would
highly recommend you to take the basic
subscription on T by info platform and
uh and start your research Journey
because in this subscription you will
get access to all the resources that we
have on omics logic learn which involves
the projects and all the tutorials also
so it helps you to do this on your own
and if when you are not sure or when you
are when you are don't have when you
have not enough time you know to do this
dedicatedly and you think that you would
start in maybe December or maybe in
January in that case you should do the
take the subscription on omis logic
learn and start with the courses here
and in the courses you will be able to
do all those things that uh vedika was
talking about if I give you an uh
example of you know these coding lessons
you will find that there are code blocks
that you can run and learn about coding
which is both are in Python very
important in today's skill set world
looking which is being looked upon by
industry so here also you will be able
to run all of the pipelines so this is a
more tutorial based Hands-On courses so
these are not like typical theoretical
courses that you see other way otherwise
these are mostly Hands-On courses which
involves going through a practical
example going through a data set so in
this entire experience you learn about
how to how to interpret analyze and what
type of transcriptomics or you know gene
expression data is all there so you
learn about the history what are the
ways RNA can be Quantified you're
thinking you'll you're kind of analyzing
RNA so you you know about all the things
that could quantify RNA first and then
how big data like how Next Generation
sequencing is is helping in several of
these uh discoveries in several of these
uh products and all of that so it it
obviously there are some other lessons
that you would have to do to learn about
Advanced statistics and machine learning
but all of that is included in the basic
subscription which is just for ten
dollars so
um I think this is what I wanted to kind
of uh tell you all today uh if there are
any other questions so there are some
questions I can see in the chat what is
the difference between starter Education
and Research packages
so we have not started the uh
educational and research packages here
but yeah the research package is uh when
you have your own data which is
generated from your own lab and which is
not available on public repository so in
that case uh you you would have to
upload the data on our FTP server and
that requires that research license so
if you're working for a research club
and you don't want the data to be public
and you want to work on that
confidentially so our team enables that
and we apply all the data compliances
and we help you with the research per
project so that's the research monthly
license to uh me to access the Tiba info
server and run with your own data now
educational which is not as available
right now is uh the projects and courses
which are developed by industry experts
so many of the industry experts are
working with us and developing many cool
projects really really cool projects
from Clinical informatics to you know
drug Discovery so those will be
available as we are completing those and
putting them on learn so once they are
available we will have the educational
45 subscription also available right now
it's a great opportunity because right
now we don't have all of this ready but
we have the starter subscription ready
which has 36 courses I mean for ten
dollars so I these are these are courses
that will help you understand not about
one discipline but uh different types of
performix data analysis you will learn
about machine learning data science you
will learn about infectious diseases you
will learn about cancer cancer you you
can choose about all those
specializations which are also included
in this including microbiome research
and you know all of that so I mean
that's what uh it is and if there are
any further questions I will be happy to
answer those or else we will just
conclude this meeting and I will hope to
see you join our programs and
interacting with us and going through
this almost logic Journey
over to you srigori for the conclusion
and then we can meet again very soon
yes so in the chat box I'm sharing the
contact details of spare style so you
can reach out to her for if you're
having any queries regarding the
research fellowship program and if the
participants have more further queries
uh we are good to end today's meeting so
I look forward to seeing you all for the
program and with that thank you and have
a great day bye